one flap of a butterfly's wing in brazil
would be enough to cause a hurricane in
indonesia
edward norton lorenz
[Music]
1893 kyoto
japan
young lawyer henry stimson and his wife
mabel white are on the honeymoon in
kyoto the newlyweds are stunned by the
colorful oriental city and its ancient
history
they will remember this visit for the
rest of their lives
may 11
1945
los alamos usa
a special us army committee makes a list
of priority targets for atomic bombings
kyoto is top on the list as the largest
industrial center in japan
pointing to the city's large cultural
significance the ministry of defense
henry stimson crosses it out from the
list personally this makes hiroshima the
main target for the us army
next in line at risk of bombing is the
town of kakura
august 9th
1945
japan
the crew of the u.s air force b-29
bomber is given a specially important
order by the commanders
the military arsenal in kakura must be
raised to the ground
a state-of-the-art bomb more powerful
than any used before is loaded on board
the aircraft for the mission
however the town is enveloped in a fog
so thick that the crew cannot
distinguish the target
the aircraft captain charles sweeney
takes a decision to fly on
to the town of nagasaki
thus some sentimental reminiscences of
50 years back and an ordinary weather
event affected the destinies of millions
of people
and this story is just one of a great
multitude of examples where seemingly
small events may give rise to major
consequences incredible in their scale
this phenomenon is commonly perceived as
the butterfly effect
but in reality it is actually just a
part of a big field of science known as
chaos theory
[Music]
in order to have a clearer insight into
the correlation between small arthropods
and destructive weather events let's
travel back to the recent past
in 1961 mathematician and meteorologist
edward lorenz attempted to forecast the
behavior of atmospheric flows by means
of computer modelling the scientist
assumed that thanks to new computing
capabilities he would be able to predict
the weather with an unprecedented
accuracy
however the results of the calculations
baffled the scientist
in order to try to speed up the
calculation process lorenz divided it
into stages so that the final results of
the previous stage would be the starting
conditions for the one coming next
some of the resulting figures were
slightly rounded up by the computer
this was so negligible that it was not
supposed to have any significant impact
on the final answer
or so the scientists thought
however
in reality it turned out that the
results of uninterrupted and stage by
stage calculations differed dramatically
later studies revealed that the system
of equations lorenz was trying to solve
was inadequate for atmospheric processes
modeling
still as is often the case in science
a misformulated task proved to be a step
to an amazing and unexpected discovery
in his search for answers the
mathematician found that all possible
solutions of the system group around two
conventional positions which he dubbed
attractors
if every solution were to be represented
by a dot in a 3d coordinate system they
eventually form a shape reminiscent of a
butterfly's wings
interestingly the slightest change of
any initial parameter may sharply
transfer the final calculation result
from one wing to the other in fact
lorenz was not the first to discover an
effect like that
similar ideas were expressed by german
philosopher johann fichte and french
mathematician andrey puankare in their
works
be it as it may it was lorenz who
transformed the annoying era of
mathematical modelling into a potent and
elaborate theory capable of offering
answers to many questions
[Music]
it goes without saying that hundreds of
scientists would have contributed to the
notion of chaos in the decades that
followed and the theory itself has come
a long way its mechanisms can be applied
to describe such complex phenomena and
processes as turbulent flows evolution
of biological species
social interactions and stock exchange
quotes
the laws of chaos define the movement of
celestial objects and explosions of
stars
the birth of empires and the demise of
continents
and in order to get to the bottom of
these factors and regularities first and
foremost the notion of chaos has to be
defined from the point of view of
science
first of all it should be noted that any
chaotic structure is subject to rather
rigid and clear physical laws but they
are so complex that the behavior of a
system appears to be unpredictable it is
for a reason that structures like that
are also known as deterministic chaos
with reference to their behavior being
predefined
this is the principal feature that
distinguishes them from stochastic
systems which are based on truly random
events
if a chaotic system's behavior is
supervised several times the initial
conditions being absolutely identical
it will react in the same manner
as for a structure based on pure chance
meanwhile
the result will never be the same
for example experiments show that the
decay of unstable nuclei in a sample of
radioactive material occurs exclusively
by chance
we can calculate the approximate number
of atoms transforming within a specified
period of time but the current stage of
technological development it is
impossible to predict the precise time a
given nucleus is supposed to decay
the exact mathematical definition of
chaos sounds like this
a system has to exhibit non-linear
characteristics be globally stable but
at the same time have at least one
oscillating equilibrium point
at the same time the system's fractal
dimension must not be less than 1.5
it's quite a challenge to get one's head
around this convoluted phrase unless one
is a professional mathematician of
course rather than a layman
in simple words it may be expressed by
three principal points
firstly the system has to be non-linear
let's imagine we're influencing a
structure in one way or another and
getting a predictable feedback
it is logical to assume that after
several interactions of this kind the
resulting change will equal the sum of
all single ones
however it isn't the case for a
non-linear system
and as a result the structure will
change more or less than we estimated
this was the effect encountered by
lorenz in his calculations which
prompted him to carry on with his
studies
secondly
a dynamic chaos system must be
responsive to the initial conditions
that is to exhibit this very butterfly
effect this means that no matter how
tiny and almost completely negligible
change of the initial conditions may be
it may force the system to develop in a
completely different manner
thirdly as a system develops its
separate parts are supposed to overlap
and interact with each other
such interactions are usually not taken
into account in classical physics
however quite often it proves to be a
grave emission
it is keeping track of multifaceted
influence that makes chaos theory models
so elaborate and so like real structures
let's think 13.8 billion years back
just a few quanta of time would have
elapsed since the occurrence of the
hypothetical big bang
there is neither matter nor energy
around us as we know them and the four
fundamental interactions are
interconnected by one bizarre force
the physical laws known to us are not
yet applicable at this point
however other ones are working instead
which are just as rigid and which
predefine the system's future
development
at the same time a tiniest change in any
point of the germinating universe is
capable of changing its future
completely
whatever the reason for this tiny change
it appears that our reality was
literally born actually thanks to chaos
in the scientific sense of the word
now let's imagine what it's like about a
million years later
the space of that time would have become
more like what we know to be
although there aren't any stars or
planets around
there are only countless clouds of
primary hydrogen
floating around the young universe
the hydrogen is exposed to gravity
forces pressure this forms gravity
centers which are soon to become the
first stars
these gas clusters are splashed about
quite irregularly with no system to
speak of
they're also massive enough to mutually
exert gravitational influence
at the same time with any of the protest
stars moved aside or with its mass
slightly altered these changes will
influence not only its own evolution but
that of its immediate neighbors as well
this means that the laws of chaos
continue to rule the universe
in the course of billions of years that
followed primary stars burned out and
exploded saturating the universe with
heavy elements
new stars were born from clusters of
hydrogen with clouds of cosmic dust near
them swirling in gigantic vortices and
forming protoplanetary disks
it is easy to see the already familiar
patterns of chaotic movement and
interaction in their structure
and this is how four and a half billion
years ago the solar system was born
[Music]
this tale could go on indefinitely
supernovas formation of celestial bodies
atmospheric phenomena and ocean currents
wherever we cast our eyes there are
examples of deterministic chaos around
us all over the place
its laws determine how children turn out
when they grow up
how the economy develops and how society
changes
the entire universe is permeated with
myriads of connections
and every one of us is part of this
system
and it looks that a tiny butterfly in a
remote corner of the planet
has just flapped its wing
[Music]
[Applause]
you